if I had Google glass I didn't known
already yeah if I had that memory link
why everything that Jamie's worried
about Jamie's gonna be the first one to
get it then he's gonna like organize to
make sure that no one else that's it my
thought on that too is like we're gonna
be the first one to get it and how yeah
aside that um well for sure like money
Marcus Brownlee and Lou from unbox
therapy they'll get it first and they'll
put it on and then they'll start running
the world that doesn't have it girlie
and then go out no one else gets this
but Mark Zuckerberg probably already has
it you don't want to know what is it
right now yeah offend his case yeah it's
um it's coming something's coming yeah
man what's it gonna be who knows what's
gonna be yeah something's coming and
something's gonna be more invasive than
what we're experiencing now mm-hmm so I
can be sure of they're gonna figure out
to get more and more data you know sam
harris has a really interesting podcast
that's out it's either the one that's
going on right maybe the two weeks ago
and it was all about i should probably
find it it was all about privacy privacy
and what's the difference between the
way different tech companies approach
privacy that actually makes you respect
how Apple does it oh yeah yeah I mean
they apparently they do it much more I
guess the world would be they're more
ethical about it uh-huh they're trying
not to give away any the trouble with
Facebook is what's called I was reading
a thing yesterday that you know you put
those doorbell things on you know like
ring you know that records people coming
up to you and they said you know you
think it's cool for you and your family
but the UPS guy all these delivery
people are getting their picture taken
and sent to a database every day like
these people are being monitored all the
time so well it's good for you it's not
that great for these other people that
visit you this guy's name is Roger
McNamee that's the one it's the trouble
of Facebook it's episode 152 it's really
it's very interesting because that what
what goes into is about how tech
companies figured out how to tap into a
resource that no one
thought of and that resources your data
mm-hmm how much is that worth well it
turns out it's worth fucking untold
billions right it's one of the most
valuable things because it you can
direct market to people you could find
out what people are into what they're
not into yeah you get a you get a lot of
people that you can get a hold of and we
kind of gave our consent to this without
understanding it yeah and they got in
through a loophole and this is how
they're able to make you know ungodly
amounts of money just because we wanted
to have that cool feature so you just
say yeah here's take it from me I mean
think about the amount of money
something like facebook brings in versus
what it is like what is it what are you
doing what are you doing this making all
that money right they're providing
people with data yeah you know and
they're also getting people to it's like
an ongoing psychological experiment in
what makes people engage mmm and what
makes people comment more right it's out
it's anger oh really
yeah it turns out that what makes people
engage the most is things they disagree
with when they started having fights and
fights back and forth so you you get
people to get really into these
polarizing subject right and then you
once they start looking for those
subjects then those subjects start
showing up in their feeds it's all such
things they get angry about so then they
start interacting with these things the
more you interact the more more it shows
up in your feed and all the while
they're profiting on enraging you oh my
god I mean this is essentially what they
do see Facebook patent uses image
recognition to scan your personal photos
for brands oh my god yeah so they just
take all your photos and burrito bags in
the back applying computer vision
algorithms to user uploaded multimedia
objects to detect specific objects
within the multimedia object and
promoting the uploaded multimedia object
from a user's newsfeed to a Sponsored
Stories area that's what the patent was
awarded for Wow a vision content
detection for Sponsored Stories wow
that's crazy man
yeah
you snap a selfie sippin a unicorn
frappe at Starbucks and shares that
selfie on Facebook or Instagram
Facebook's new we patented technology
can theoretically scan the photo spot
the Starbucks cup with the help of an
image object recognition algorithm and
then sell that info to Starbucks
alerting the coffee giant of the fact
that you like its product well they're
already doing a version of that with
your searches yeah things you're looking
at you know when you go through their
browse or they're already doing that
well they're doing it also with voice
your phone is listening to you all the
time yeah if you have Alexa in your home
it's listening mm-hmm my kids and we we
do it all the time like you talking
about something and then all of a sudden
you see I was performing in Boise and so
we were talking about Boise Boise Boise
and then everybody on their Instagram
was getting an ad for vacationing and
Boise see that seems gesture must
speaking it yeah that seems like a
really serious thing it is it seems like
a really serious thing that everybody is
just like oh this is happening yeah I
remember signing off on this the
technologies ahead of our anger or our
recognition yeah we don't understand
yeah so it's already happened by the
time you're upset that it exists right
yeah it's it's in full full force right
now yeah yeah it's really weird it's
really weird it's really weird and we're
just talking about it this is just we
think it's you're just in in your home
you're in a private place mm-hmm
yeah but these phones they're this list
you know and again this is something
that didn't exist 10 years ago 15 years
ago these concerns didn't exist yeah
what would be the concerns 15 years from
now look how much more invasive as its
going to get before we even recognize
that it's happening yeah cuz this is
this is something the listening in on
things is something that people didn't
think about before it happened right now
they know it does well the face
recognition thing is there's a lot of
articles on that and how that you don't
realize what the China game totally
makes sense right especially yeah so
many people's phones use face
recognition software right well the
Samsung phones have it you know my
Galaxy Note 9 has it yeah iPhones have
it yeah yeah and you're just psyched
about it you
just like oh that's cool I don't have to
put in my password anymore mhm just
looked at yeah I'm in my app they also
have one that's an iris scanner on the
note the note scans your irises oh
really yeah
Wow it's quick - looks your eyeballs
like yep you're you fuck do you know man
what does that say Jamie I was trying to
find this the first time you brought up
but I know that there's these masks that
exist that are in quotes like
hyper-realistic masks they can be used
to I don't know if it's this is used to
help the face recognition but I think
people are using them to trick it and do
fake stuff and like you know if you
could commit a robbery with that on and
just like having a ski mask on now they
just can't see her face but it'll think
if you had a hoodie on yeah
what about in Minority Report remember
when they had to pull his eye they were
selling eyeballs on the black market for
the eye scan to get into Bill all you
have to do with that is put like a
bandana around your mouth right yeah so
it could no one could see your mouth
moving have that thing on sunglasses
yeah but my even my iPhone gets through
my sunglasses which I don't know how I
know so what's facial recognition so
yeah but what I'm saying is with this
like if you wanted to rob someone and
have something like even with the facial
recognition software would would think
that it would legitimately think you
were somebody else
hopefully no and what about hopefully if
we're wondering doing our job someone
yeah we're trying to rob so hopefully
not Beauty guys criminals it's crazy
it's gonna happen wait it's so fast too
I mean no you know this is so new but
also the like the special effects
technology that allows people to make
faces okay look how beautiful those
things look yeah it's so close to a
person yeah these for 200 bucks you I
want to do it I should buy you and that
would be cool that'd be crazy
see if we can open up your phone look
super creepy but oh that's so weird
oh you guys are a demon if they got a
little latex it could be movable it'd be
kind of wow that looks pretty real
though I mean you know a little creepy
but that looks pretty
that's crazy act I wouldn't look twice
on the walk down the street he wouldn't
even think about it now
you'd be like that guy is a good shave
it's a beautiful person his skin so
smooth the baby's bottom it was started
off that's my face calm and it's not
been switched to whatever this is your
mean survey